gasoline shortage in Florida is making
it even harder for people trying to get
out of hermas path we have seen this
everywhere we go 42% of gas stations in
Miami and Fort Lauderdale are empty
according to the Gas Buddy app 44% are
out of gas in West Palm Beach 37% are
empty in Tampa st. pete david Begg knows
at a Turnpike rest stop in Pompano Beach
just north of Miami here where evacuates
are trying to fill up david jeff good
morning the weather couldn't be better
for getting out of town here in Pompano
Beach we found fuel that's why we wanted
to tell you where it was in case you're
evacuating north as you pull into the
Shell station here there are 32 pumps in
Pompano Beach where right off the
Florida Turnpike so if you're headed
north to Orlando you can't miss it
guys will wave you in right now it's
pretty nice you see car after car
pulling in but there's not a really big
line this morning in fact as you drive
in you've got the Florida Highway Patrol
that's policing this situation these
gentlemen with red flags will stop you
there in case there's a line at the pump
and if you notice the traffic moving
north on the on the Turnpike is flowing
moving nicely right now in the city of
Miami though it's a whole lot tougher to
take a look this man left Miami and says
he couldn't find an open gas station for
nearly 70 miles he had to push his car
to the pump it becomes very difficult to
keep up with that level of demand
patrick de haan senior petroleum analyst
at gas buddy put some of the blame on
hurricane harvey which knocked out oil
refineries in Texas the fact that fuel
supply is already constrained is making
the situation I'm almost as bad as it
gets the Trump administration has eased
regulations to get gas to stations more
quickly Governor Rick Scott has ordered
police escorts for tanker trucks for gas
stations and evacuation zones we need
you stay open as long as possible so
people can get out we will arrange
police escorts for your employees so
they can get out safely those flying out
of Emma's path face long lines at
airports more than 4,000 flights have
been canceled
American Airlines will stop flying from
its Miami hub this afternoon Delta is
using bigger planes to take more than
2,000 people out of the region hopefully
the storm will stay on
tract won't get here till Saturday and
we'll be out of here also on the move
the US Coast Guard which started on
Thursday clearing out its helicopters
and planes they don't plan to be back to
do rescues until earnest gone so if the
Coast Guard's leaving I should probably
give you an indication of the severity
of this storm if you've got the Gas
Buddy app on your phone it's being
updated in real time by the way here in
Pompano Beach this is a great place to
get fuel it's right off the Turnpike you
exit to the left-hand side and the gas
station owner tells us we're staying
open as long as we can no closing time
set that's the first gas station I've
seen here that hasn't had blocks
multiple blocks long a wait David thank
you very much